more clark county school district
students are returning to buildings
tomorrow for classes in person
now this comes after pre-kindergarten to
third grade students went back earlier
this month
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with more on preparations and what we
can expect
kristen sasha the district anticipates
about 27
thousand students in grades 6 9 and 12
starting hybrid learning tomorrow
it's a very big day following more than
a year of distance education
for secondary school students i'm so
excited to be going back
eager and enthusiastic honestly like an
answer to my prayers
macy beck welcomes taking classes in
person again at sierra vista high school
having conversations with students my
age
is exciting but i also just don't know
what it's going to be like and it is a
little bit nerve-racking
what's so nerve-wracking about it going
back to normal just seems
not right in a way but at the same time
it's something that i've wanted
so bad the senior and student body
president expects an adjustment
so to ease those returning she and the
student council decorated parts of the
school
we have like four different hallways
that we deck out in the theme to
have the students get excited about
coming back all middle and high school
buildings making various preparations
before
monday that includes positioning desks
for social distancing
our custodians are phenomenal and they
actually set up our classrooms for us
billy hemberger teaches at spring valley
high school he says
the big concern starting monday the
hybrid schedule
students take two classes in person then
finish the school day remotely online
the morning courses are now an hour and
45 minutes
there's no way to prepare other other
than
for me anyway i'm just going to kind of
do it and learn as
learn as i go are there any concerns
with the new hybrid schedule i'd be
lying if i said it made sense to me
because it doesn't but for beck it beats
the alternative of continuing full-time
distance education if this is what we
have to work with then we'll work with
it
so the district gave students a choice
of returning to campuses or not
and split them among three cohorts here
you go this is what it's on this uh your
screen
cohort a goes to class in person on
monday and tuesday and attends their
courses remotely online wednesday
through friday
cohort b has class online monday through
wednesday
and goes to campus thursday and friday
cohort c is
full-time distance education now on
april 6th
the rest of the grade levels will go
back in buildings elementary schools
will then transition from hybrid
learning
to classes in person five days a week
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now